>>Narrator: Childhood obesity
and related health problems have
been rising at an alarming rate
across the country due in part to
the food choices kids have at school.
>>Bonnie: You see things like frozen
pizza, fries, things that have a lot
of preservatives, things
that have been processed.
We don't do any of that.
>>Narrator: In some schools, like
the Martin Luther King Middle School
in Berkeley, California,
parents, teachers, administrators,
and food-service providers are
demanding better-quality food
for their children.
>>Bonnie: The Berkeley Unified
school-lunch program started years
ago with a number of families
who were really concerned
about what was happening in
the public-school cafeterias.
>>Narrator: 39 percent of students
in the Berkeley Unified
School District receive free
or reduced lunch.
Including overhead, the food program
spends an average of 4 dollars
and 50 cents per lunch, well
above the national average
of 2 dollars and 91 cents.
The program is able to make up the
difference and thrive with grants.
>>Bonnie: There are a lot of people
and there are a lot of organizations
that are invested in
children eating healthy.
We applied for grants for
equipment, ovens, stoves,
retherms, all sorts of things.
The money is there.
>>This is soy, and if you have the
right mixture, the right blends
of seasonings and sauce,
everything, they love it.
>>Narrator: Martin Luther King Middle
School also runs the nationally
recognized Edible Schoolyard program,
where students get
hands-on experience
in their organic garden
and kitchen classroom.
>>Now, where do you
think this came from?
>>All: Garden.
>>Right out there.
>>Narrator: In this
integrated learning environment,
teachers incorporate gardening
and food preparation into lessons
in science, mathematics...
>>Woman: If it calls for
one-and-a-half cups of cooked pumpkin
and we're doubling the recipe,
then how much do we need?
>>Three.
>>Narrator: ...history,
ecology, and culture.
>>See, just making it
hot, just toasting it,
gives it a different flavor.
>>Narrator: Students
learn about the connection
between their everyday food choices
and the health of the community,
the environment, and themselves.
>>Alice: This is a delicious
revolution that we're talking about.
This isn't hard to do.
If they grow it, they cook
it, they want to eat it.
>>Bonnie: Our kids who participate
in the garden cooking classes eat
three times more vegetables and fruit
than kids who do not, and so the
proof is in the pudding, as they say.
>>Beautiful!
Now we're going to bring
it right over here.
>>Narrator: Along with
lots of veggies and fruits,
King Middle serves up kid favorites
like pizza and mac and cheese.
But here, there is a nutritious
twist on foods kids love.
>>Bonnie: We make our
macaroni and cheese here fresh.
We boil 300 pounds
of pasta to do that.
We make a low-fat cheese sauce with
fresh cheese and Organic Valley milk.
It's completely healthy.
It is not processed.
It is sustainable.
It is local.
It's something that anybody can do,
and the kids absolutely love it.
>>Caleb: I think that King is setting
a good example for other schools
to have a more healthier lifestyle.
Like, the healthy food
actually can taste good.
I mean, I really enjoy the food here.
>>Bonnie: To replicate this
program, it takes a community
that demands real food that is
healthy, nutritious, and sustainable
in their communities, and they have
to stand up for it and they have
to stand up and make a
lot of noise about it.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.